[Music]
as the busy summer travel season gets
closer the FAA is opening what it calls
highways in the sky to speed up air
travel Travelers want to know if
America's Aviation system can keep up
with demand from Summer vacationers
Chris Van Cleave is at Los Angeles
International Airport LAX Chris good
morning
Nate good morning we'll start with some
good news airfare tracking site Hoppers
says domestic airfares for the summer
are down more than 10 percent compared
to last year but flyer concern appears
to be on the rise more than 75 percent
of Flyers say they are worried about
their flights being disrupted delayed or
canceled and for good reason 22 percent
of flights so far this year that's more
than one in five has been delayed and
the airports are only going to get more
crowded from here
this morning the countdown to summer
vacation comes with concern over travel
turmoil I'm on a wing and a prayer
Sherry izenman is so concerned about her
three-week trip to Ireland in June she's
not even checking a bag I really believe
it's just kind of 50 50.
anyone traveling is taking a chance
that they may not get to their
destination
last summer more than 45 000 flights
were canceled and nearly one in four was
delayed as Airlines struggled through
bad weather and snapping issues this
year they insist it will be different
bookings are strong demand is strong
we're adding buffers into our own
schedules to make certain we can deliver
for our consumers all of our partners
really want to make sure this summer
goes smoothly while the TSA expects
potentially record-breaking numbers of
passengers at U.S airports this summer
ticketing Pilots seeking a new contract
warn there could be turbulence ahead the
summer at American Airlines is as
uncertain as it was last year and last
year was not good the FAA announced it's
opened new highways in the Sky by
streamlining 169 East Coast routes
saving 6 000 minutes of travel time
annually but Air Traffic Control
Staffing concerns prompted Airlines to
reduce summer flights out of New York
City I'm worried Airlines have scheduled
more flights than the FAA can handle
airline industry analyst Henry
hartzebelt I think this is going to be a
summer of light to moderate turbulence
I'm concerned that if there's just even
the slightest Ripple of bad weather the
FAA will be asking Airlines to delay
flights or possibly even cancel flights
because there are more flights than the
system can safely handle
Sherry izenman just hopes she makes her
connection they've already changed it
twice
and it keeps getting closer and closer
to my departure time to go to Dublin
now Airlines have largely addressed
their staffing issues from last year but
the biggest disrupter to Summer travel
traditionally is the weather Best Bets
are non-stop flights that leave on the
early side of the morning and if there
is bad weather in the forecast and the
airlines suggests you change your flight
be proactive do it early while there are
options still available Tony
yeah well the airlines can't control the
weather my worst thing with Airlines is
when you land you're there and they
can't get you to the gate the gate is
full and you're just sitting there Chris
thank you very much appreciate it wish
people the best of luck this summer